your first time first time well you know
I don't like to talk about your mom but
uh
[Music]
Miami what a town
I love it here fun people
been here three days and I think I'm
gonna get lip injections and become
Cuban
the Cuban women those asses that's a
hell of a BBL holy hell I love I have
the dick link to penetrate one of those
I don't think I could do it big I mean I
assume that's uh most of you floated
here but uh
comedy
um
yeah I love Florida something about this
state you know right when I land I just
want to a guy's wife
there's something in the air here you
just want to do meth up a gay guy's ass
you know
yeah it's wild out here I feel so free
the state flag of Florida should be fake
tits a handgun and a coked up iguana and
a jet ski
all right all right comedy okay
you're from Louisiana oh yeah
what do I sound like
[Applause]
all right
sound like a gay Seinfeld all right
what's the deal with
oh so good
I love being insidewatch
Mark Norman
airplane sucks I heard I heard 9 11.
9 11.
huh Arab
oh 911 really woke up huh
are you Arab
IC yeah oh
is that the burqa is that is that
another group
that's another group who does the person
um
[Music]
ironically there's an Arab here and I'm
bombing
we got an immigrants here hey where you
from
observices
okay either way I'm sure you have
trouble at the airport all right
well good to have you buddy okay sorry
that joke is over the line and so are
you but uh all right all right
immigrants are great too because
immigrants tend to appreciate America
more than most Americans I'm from here
I'm born and raised I'm spoiled I take
it for granted my grandparents are
immigrants from Sicily they never shut
the hell up they're like the American
dream the freedom the opportunity and
I'm like where the my ubereats
where the hell is that algebra Gerber
with my food
anybody else with a comment vegan oh
good one good one vegans are interesting
because uh my buddy's a vegan very
sensitive guy I'm walking on eggshells
around him he really hates that but uh
yeah
vegans are interesting because you hate
meat but you eat a lot of meat like
it's like not dog toe furkey fake and
it's like it's weird to hate some but
once I'm just like it you know it's kind
of like a lesbian with a strap on
all right
you hate dick but it looks like a dick
feels like a dick I Can't Believe It's
Not dick
it's beyond dick
yeah
My Vegan friend is a I love him to death
but he gives me a lot of all day
long he's like I can't believe you eat
animal products and I caught him biting
his nails the other day I was like
someone said Jeffrey Dahmer oh have you
seen it it's great right you know it's
funny it's getting all this blowback
because it's like
this is problematic he black man
and it's got the lgbtq tag on it you're
like that's the problem
what about the murdering and
eating food
the least problematic thing about the
movie is the murderer no one
cares about that they're like ah gays
I'm like he ain't the guy
that's how obsessive with identity
politics like wow they're gays they're
people he ain't people
I love the I love the moment too when
the cop tells his dad like I got bad
news your son's gay he's a serial killer
and he's a cannibal the dad's like oh
he's gay yeah
oh no this is horrible news
1899 oh sorry I didn't know people
didn't know he was gay you guys ever get
down your knees and thank God not a
pedophile
they didn't choose that they got dealt
about hey we're extremely lucky we
should be grateful think about how close
we all were when I was in third grade I
was attracted to third grade girls now I
like adult women when I was in third
grade I like grape juice now I like red
wine but I still like grape juice
holy hell that was close
thank God my brain just knew the right
way to go
my friends broke he just bought a
Peloton you ever see one of these things
two thousand dollars for this thing
could you imagine explaining a Peloton
at somewhere in a third world country
whoa you spent two grand on a bike must
be pretty fast nah doesn't move
done moved I know you know he just sits
in the living room oh it sits in the
living room so when you pedal it it must
generate power for your home no use a
lot of power it's got a big screen on
the front big screen oh so when you
usually watch funny TV shows no actually
a better looking person screams at you
the whole time
well this thing sounds terrible what's
the upside well you know eat too much
takeout you got to burn some calories
whoa whoa what's takeout oh that's where
a guy on a bicycle brings food to your
house and you pay him
wait a minute this guy's got a real bike
and you give him money why wouldn't you
just do that what am I a
immigrant
[Music]
this is the best time in history a
grown-up by the way we can do whatever
we want
have you noticed grown-ups are having a
blast now and kids are miserable it's
all completely flipped when I was a kid
every grown-up was pissed off defeated
get off my lawn now my friends are 42
all they do is play video games read
comic books and watch pro wrestling
and every teenager I see now is obsessed
with politics and on medication
we won
it's all flipped
flip my dad was my age he had two kids a
law degree and owned a home I have Hulu
thank you
like I just got back from Europe they
really make fun of us over there that's
like all they do oh you Americans you're
so fat uh like yeah we're doing great
why is it a bad thing how fat we are I
think it's cool it's like impressive
more people die in America of obesity
than starvation which is like hey we did
it
how cool are we we're dying from eating
food we go up to heaven some guys like I
starve to death what happened to you
we're like snacks
yeah the McRib is back what do you want
I said well how'd you lose your foot
frostbite nah frosting
yeah we're fat
I'm so high up on the food chain one of
my friends he only eats grass-fed beef
you realize how crazy that is that means
he gets to pick what he eats eats
it's pretty good
and here's the weird thing cows eat
grass that's what we mess with our food
when something eats what it's supposed
to we brag about it that's like saying
hey you know my four-year-old is sober
[Music]
how the hell did that happen just tell
me the news tell me the story I don't
want your spin or your bias thank God we
don't do that with the weather
wouldn't that be insane if we had
political opinionated weather
like Hey we're going to the beach
tomorrow let's check the left-wing
weather
hey folks 90 degrees outside beautiful
day for an abortion
we got some dark clouds coming in excuse
me clouds of color and uh
as you can see we got tropical storm
Kelly abreuin slowly transition to
Hurricane Kevin but we don't judge and
uh
we're not sure what the future holds but
we know it's female back to you they
them holy moly is just trying to get the
goddamn weather that was weird I got
nothing out of that all right let's
check the right wing weather maybe
that'll be a little more informative the
right wing weather
hey folks grab your boots it's 100
chance of storming the capital
[Music]
ing out there and
uh we got some ice in the midwest we
need some ice at the border I'll tell
you that right now and uh
grab your coats because we hate
snowflakes
praise the Lord and back to you sugar
tits
[Applause]
all right